the Internet can be a dark place but
occasionally there's a spot of light one
day is sitting here at work at BuzzFeed
and they get this strange email it's
someone just telling me about their life
telling me about how their book club
tomorrow how the tree outside of their
window is blooming so spring must be
here and telling me about how their
102nd birthday is this weekend 102nd
birthday so I showed it to my desk
neighbor Ben and I was like dude Ben
what's the deal with this email from
this lady and Ben looked over and he was
like wow that's adorable
at the end of the email it's signed B B
ei I don't believe in anything spiritual
but my grandmother's name was B and of
all the members of my family I would say
I am the most similar to my grandma she
was a writer I'm a writer when my
grandma turned 80 I even portrayed her
in that family play grandma B was a very
extremely important figure in my life
and Here I am getting this email from a
woman named B so there's something too
magical about this to ignore I said
hello B I believe you have the wrong
email address though your book club and
kitchen both sound quite lovely happy
birthday cheers Jordan the magic of this
was not lost on me but I figured I'd
leave it at that so the next day I get
another email again she tried to email
this other Jordan and again she got me
so again I let her know as I get more
emails I'd show him to Ben
he'd be like that's adorable too so then
the third time he tried to get the other
Jordan and wrote I must have sent with
the wrong address once now when I start
both addresses come up you are my only
one still Sonny
B that email she also meant for the
other Jordan he was her only one not me
so I had to tell her yet again
hi B I'm afraid you still have the wrong
Jordan he responded to whoever Jordan
I'm not sure I'll ever get you started
out my 101 years has caught up with me
and I felt so bad he was starting to get
frustrated and I was worried that she
would give up and not contact the right
Jordan so I started looking for him
myself my last name spelled like it's
spelled is extremely uncommon Brian
Embry my dad Jordan and breathe me Aviva
and breathe my sister Amber and Bri my
sister-in-law
and as far as I can see those are the
only Embry's that exist on Facebook
that's only a Tim breeze in the world on
Facebook and somehow she's accidentally
getting this Jordan Embry so I start
looking for it without the middle e or
with an e at the beginning every
spelling you can think of and I'm I
can't find anything and then I have an
idea
mine's Embree IM bre uy and i tried
searching i am be e ry jordan Embry and
this guy exists I thought I was totally
alone in this world in terms of having
my exact name and this guy almost has my
exact name my name is Jordan Embry I'm
22 and I was born and raised in Langley
British Columbia and I currently live in
Chilliwack and for living I make windows
and doors I found out about B through
ancestry DNA we connected as distant
relatives
so I told us that we had a shared
ancestors and the recent past we got in
contact and found Jordan is by the
sixth-generation for me as a cousin he
was just over the line into British
Columbia
so we've carried on a conversation
you're gonna touch since last year
December she'll write me and telling me
about how her day went
tell me about her book clubs bowls that
appear in her garden I gave her advice
how to get rid of them I've never met
anybody with a similar name the Kimber
II or the same name I contacted Jordan
Embry on Facebook and said hey I think a
102 year old woman named B is trying to
contact you and it turns out it's right
but he's also never met her frankly I
wasn't willing to just say that's the
end of this story so I asked me if she'd
like to be pen pal I'm asking someone to
be your pen pals like asking them to
commit time and effort to you and why
should she care about me I'm just some
guy who she emailed by accident who she
has no relation to but luckily B is a
very kind in social person and she
agreed to be my pen pal and we've
corresponded for months ever since then
I transpose the Ian or name and I picked
up another door and this charges from
California the first one was 21 years
old the second one is 25 years old they
wrote the sweetest letter the B and I
have been corresponding since April
occasionally writing each other she
tells me all about her big extended
family and whichever grandkids birthday
is coming up and whatever big parties
they have planned I tell her about my
weird life making videos at BuzzFeed I
had an opportunity through work to go to
Mumbai for a while and he was actually
instrumental and helping me decide to
take that opportunity I think you'd
enjoy Mumbai more because it's exotic
and farther from home and maybe he had
that been there before and so then I got
there thinking I've been corresponding
with B since April Jordan in burries
been corresponding with her for a while
longer neither of us have met her in
person neither of us have met each other
why don't we do it we're gonna go to B's
house we're gonna go to her book club
we're gonna have a big dinner with her
family we're all just gonna get to know
each other I don't really know what to
expect what I want to get out of this
experience meeting B would probably be
your life experience what I was like
growing up in the 20s 30s 40s 50s her
secret to her longevity because I want
to live to 105 in check when the world
has come to me this time I'm super
excited and nervous for me a guy with
the same name as me and I 102 year old
pen pal to all meet IRL Jordan Embry
hey Jordan Embry yeah nice - nice to
meet you in real life yeah you too
is it pronounced in Barry or umber E or
umber II in burry or in Barry but it's
not Embry no no one says Embry sometimes
so we're different I get called me Embry
sometimes is not correct can you correct
people like Embry is a [ __ ] name -
yes - a better name how long has this
name been in your family hundreds of
youth
really okay yours this has been around
longer mine is an Ellis Island James a
lot of Jews that came from Eastern
Europe and stuff would change their name
so they'd sound more American
Pennsylvania Dutch Mennonite roots they
moved to Waterloo Ontario and from there
my family went to BC her family went to
Washington Steve any big thing you're
hoping to learn from meeting her
yeah I like to learn what she's been
eating it's giving her that longevity
because I would like to make it to year
2100 okay so do you think the biggest
thing she has to teach us is how he
helped
we got books on that already I want some
like profound insight about like what it
is to be a human but I think that's a
lot to ask someone I wanna know what I
was like I guess grow from that dirty
thirties do what do you think it was
like quite depressing maybe worse that's
not what she's emailing you she messaged
me and she's like I writ your email
wrong I've been writing this Jordan
California and so I guess you don't know
what my flowers are blooming I guess I
don't right
did it annoy you a little bit of some
other Jordan embryo is coming in and
starting to pen pal with your pen pal
yes the more the merrier
you're a good guy we're getting into the
woods now is this house I think it's
white it's
well then what's the attorney that's
supposed to always be blooming ya em cuz
their loss to them one of the things
that's crazy about being a hundred - is
that her kids are in their seventies I
was in Jordan
honorary Jordan my right cousin she's
been looking forward to it since I think
August where you came back and started
talking about it it has been a big deal
for the family yeah because it's a big
deal to her this is what she lives for
big moments new adventures so we're
hanging Titan beast garage while our
camera crew sets up for us to meet her
this is B's car Kirk said she hasn't
driven it since she was 99 years old
since she's not 102 that's a long time
to drive see look at that interior nice
red burgundy topaz chrome trim
untrammeled I just wonder you think it'd
be as a hugger or hand-shaker they have
look we don't actually know her we only
know everybody email so what's
appropriate like because we read owners
don't even say things like greeting no
hello both Georgia yeah this is no okay
cousin well I could tell you you're not
the same size so I can tell that's right
yeah nice to meet you in person
well I'm glad to meet all you people mr.
oh my gosh absolutely hunter one things
are easy to give ya don't cost anything
you can't imagine how much excitement
that's created and I have this friend
that is in deep into genealogy something
that she sent this one little email and
I answered and there you were that's
what created all this how long have you
been doing book club I think I've only
been in about eight years it's a lot of
books I'm not gonna finish the book this
time but I'm not really as fast as I
thought I was and I'm just not gonna do
it at the end of it you got rid of your
moles yeah there's one one tract left
out there's a little black box on the
far side of the lawn 19:15 it's a secret
oh I think mines be good genes you know
that's just the way it is just before my
hundredth birthday and I was going
through immigration man looked at my
passport and looked at me and looked at
my passport and gave it back to me
he left his cherry came around and
stooped down I level with me he says we
were really born in 1915
I said I was and everybody within
hearing distance stopped looked what was
your favorite decade I don't know well I
was younger I used to hope I would lift
if you see the two thousand dollar
challenger and here I have gone through
a lot of calendars in truth can you tell
us a little bit about your house like
moved into an inn during the 10th 1941
my dad built the house this is about B
Mathewson this kind of sums it up one
day this guy came by it was in the
evening and he wanted coal it's a sack
of coal it was a doll or a sack and he
said I can go down the if the Quorum get
it forgot he sins places that's the
place together well they're close tight
is what you're talking about 10 cents if
you could wouldn't you yeah it also made
a comment about where's your husband I
wouldn't have my wife out here doing
this and she's no but you'd chisel me
out of 10 cents
having lived 102 years would you say you
lived carefully like did you smoke drink
to stay out late no I didn't do those
things when I was growing up it was a
big potatoes type you know that's what
people lived so when you emailed me by
accident the first time and then I later
asked if you would be my pen pal
did you think it was really weird why is
this guy on a p5 pen pal oh why not this
is when you're our age what were you
doing so I'm 25 he's 21
I'm 20 I got both of our age so what
were you doing at 22 well I just had my
first child in 80 years old almost
do you remember what you're doing when
you're 26 years old till I I don't know
that's too much you should get out what
would you say like in your lifetime is
the biggest culture shift that you can
remember well I think it's almost right
now the lack of respect that people give
that the younger generation gives to our
older people and the kids that go by
here very seldom do whatever does I
contact they're putting these things in
their stuff in their ears you took her
to the emergency room we were there like
till 2:00 in the morning broken 1 & 2 1
& 3 1 & 3 which
normally would probably be it so what
she'd done since she fell at 7:00 in the
morning he went down and did her laundry
twice because she had blood on her on
her stuff and she wanted to be cleaner
for that and I just worry about two days
ago that we have a unit available for me
to move into assisted living he has
lived in the same house for over 70
years and in 1972 we bought this this
finishing the headed had the house had a
little bit of remodeling done knit rows
of Washington cherry tree the carpeting
is all napal my kids will remember
skating on it with those wax when we
polish it and what again is your
relationship to be and about your third
cousins four times removed
fifth cousins twice removed so this is B
that's B and you're here a baby in that
picture is factor about oh yeah there's
the fish you know surely won't begin it
and that's the dogwood right behind her
that's the dog that's the legendary
dogwood the started this whole
interested he's gonna take aster
do you read me there pretty much maybe
they'll inspire us to get back into
eating decaf they know the difference
between decaf so how often do you all
have book club once a month we're both
saying we're hoping you guys will
inspire us to read more in who who
chooses they all do right we just wing
it well we have something known as read
it one more - is there a certain genre
you guys like to stick to I don't know
Illinois hey the last four wrong because
next month I'll be moving
I would spent two hours yesterday at
Merle Gardens and I'm tuned all other
questions my grandmother's name was
Beach she was a big writer and reader
and a participant in book clubs for a
lot of our way did you find the author's
marinade style effective I haven't
thought much about the style I didn't
hear it was very readable
well Dickens knew that he had a good
thing going but I'm sure he never
realized some great lengths that was
going to go to put you out there well
[Music]
Jordan never got the email that you
meant to send him originally which came
to me so we thought be fun to have you
read him the original email hi Jordan
from a new delft computer newer are
supposed to be easier the touch is
different but I'll keep at it
the pink dogwood I see from a kitchen
window and the light by the front door
or in bloom
I guess spring is close and preparing
for book club here next Tuesday there
are 11 we meet at 9 a.m. and serve a
light breakfast
the book is Vanity Fair by Sakura the
book is six hundred and forty pages
small print I looked it up in the
synopsis otherwise another birthday
coming next week as well
I can't believe 102 oh the Sun is coming
out time to get to work and have a good
day me that was your first email what
were you thinking then then you were
confused yeah does it make you feel to
know that this frustration was going on
just trying to talk to you I feel bad
yeah I was okay with it as long as
B replies to my emails first that's it
you're kidding me again why is you get
priority yeah your family I'm not yeah
I'm just some guy on the internet new
family are you aware of the timbre of
the names were simple similar no we had
never heard of each other oh alright
never searched my name he would always
come up because he's more well-known
right it was like did you mean Jordan
Embry
I swore in this one damn I carefully
checked before I said we'll try to find
my original letter P this is IRA's
favorite place to eat and buried I
propose a toast
hey yeah Danny a toaster toaster grandma
Jie Jie bian and
Internet Jordan here in Alabama and
wonderful relationship and we're all
happy that you guys are all here
everyone with could you break down for
us sort of how the connection happened
one more time how you connected these
two certainly we've made up her family
tree put it on ancestor Sol come about
she and I worked together and her family
has done a lot of research so I just had
to incorporate it into ancestry once her
results came back and it talks about
matches and anybody that has a potential
match will show up and Jordan emailed me
so I said that I would contact B and ask
her if it was okay for them to talk and
fees great at doing emails and so she
writes back and with it that
communication started I just want to say
thank you to all of you for being such a
generous host us and welcoming both of
us says family
he really is family and I'm just some
guy and you're welcoming me as well
undies lucky then you were both so nice
Jordans a couple years younger than me
and I never had a younger sibling and so
it kind of felt like having a little
brother I think I'll stay in touch with
Jordan and Bria we've thrown out that
idea and maybe we should switch lives
you make Windows and I make film I
expected nothing less than the best when
meeting B's family and they treated us
like family he's a very kind hearted
person fun to be around you never notice
the you know 80 year age gap feel like I
talked to her I could talk to anybody
I enjoyed it really is like I thought he
was hella fun you judge matches how his
personality comes across I notice he
helped clean after the breakfast this
morning not only a caring person but
pays attention to what goes on around
you at the end of all of this if you're
really fulfilled I made two new great
friends we spent a lot of time right now
focusing on distrust for our fellow
human try hard to remember how many
people are out there who just want to
connect with other good people feel
loved and give love
and I was really reminded of that this
week all the Internet is is a tool that
connects us it can connect us in bad
ways but it can also connect us in
beautiful ways I feel on top of the
world it's hard to tell you the lift I
felt just knowing it you admit and don't
travel a lot as I have my world come to
me it's pretty uplifting and I know
something more is going to happen
something good oh absolutely I have
maybe five of you guy came in here
feeling like a little bit like worried
that I had invaded this private thing
you two had had and I could not have
felt more wrong about that once I saw
how warm and welcoming you were to me
and offensive that we developed to envy
you were everything expected to be
you're an amazing woman Jordan you're an
awesome person too and I hope we keep in
touch and you're my new pen pal as well
well I think it's great for you to
finally knit sound like this you've each
acquired a new friend yes as well as I
have acquired several members both of
you have lived up to my expectations and
maybe beyond building this is so nice
and you know 100 returnable and one for
you yeah yeah so glad is the other it's
fun I'm glad you tuned it yeah it's been
a great day I like you Jordan
[Laughter]
[Laughter]